a lot of this did feel that we was
getting ready to go to war I was
thinking this is it what we're gonna do
staff members being in tears breaking
down everything just hit sort of that
warmups
the problem with this pandemic is is
that it's not something that's there and
it just disappears the next age when you
come to work you just worry what you're
gonna take back to your family everybody
was affected I can't I don't get if
anybody who went through this that
hasn't been affected in some way
catastrophe brings change and some of
that change has been good you just want
people to know let's be able to hold her
and give her a good squeeze this
hospital will never be the same again
and nor will the NHS people change
together like a family
I'm a midwife an affectionate father
devoted to position I have been
delivering babies of increasing cancer
patients to de cobre 19th underlit
professor Kiran Patel is performing
emergency surgery little scratch coming
up the little needle being into the skin
lying on the operating table it's 39
year old Adam Western found collapsed on
a street and has been rushed to hospital
Adams suffered a cardiac arrest and is
having a defibrillator fitted inside his
chest
professor Patel would have carried out a
procedure like this possibly hundreds of
times before but there's something very
different this operation this is surgery
carried out during a pandemic emergency
operations had to continue through the
pandemic even as the hospital struggled
to deal with the greatest health crisis
to hit the NHS professor Patel has not
had a day off since February phase one
and two where we were preparing for the
pandemic we would have probably two or
three weeks that turned into two or
three days actually so the pace of
change was quite remarkable and we saw
change in the NHS that happened over the
course of days and weeks that would
otherwise have taken years to happen
we're certainly not going back to where
we were this will be a new normal and in
fact one of the things we learn is that
we don't just stop when we achieve
something we continue to improve
[Music]
when documented another favorite ain't
never been in the critical bet
I did not been dead for nothing so they
will shot to me yeah no it's good the
University Hospital Coventry lost two
hundred and fifty three patients to
Kovac 19 more than 500 people infected
with the virus were treated and sent
back to their homes during the crisis
more than 4,000 operations were carried
out the 9,000 staff who work here are
the hospital's lifeblood they have
learned adapted and changed to function
in a covert world at the height of this
pandemic this hospital was dealing with
hundreds of coded 19 patients now there
are only four left
[Music]
6,000 babies are delivered here every
year the hospital had to prepare for
these new arrivals pandemic or not
[Music]
expectant mother Tanya followed
developments with increasing anxiety
especially I'll have my part in here
throughout the whole thing that's quite
quite scary it's been quite a lot on my
own in the ward where I was having
contractions and then you get the
anxiety that if he doesn't get here in
time the actual birth they had out of
stuff as much time as possible together
with the baby and then he hasn't been
able to see us in so it's okay going
from top of the world to actually then
not being able to see his daughter when
she's a little older and you'll be able
to tell her some of the stories about
being born during the Panda I know yeah
I think it'd be something she probably
be learning in history class at school
yeah believe it the fear of covert 19
was not limited to new moms like Tanya
but spread to the medical teams
delivering their babies although we
doctors here but you have a family back
home and I think when you come to work
you just worry what you're gonna take
back to your family I have two children
it was quite scary at the beginning
these concerns were shared across the
hospital especially by staff redeployed
to the intensive care units a lot of
miss did feel that we was getting ready
to go to war and was thinking this is it
what are we gonna do staff members being
reduced to tears because they're so
worried about their families they're
taking home with them I don't care if
anybody who went through this that
hasn't been affected in some way but I
think you know I just think I feel
personally quite proud of what we've
achieved and the
you wish you could have done more even
though there's nothing that you could do
it's upsetting you end up bottling it
off as well because you've just got to
go on to the next one and then the next
one it was sink or swim I had to just
get on with it and I have to just do it
because this is what I do we are used to
unfortunate things happening this was
happening your honor
impressive dented level absolutely these
patients were just disappearing and it
almost got to the stage where you didn't
want to ask whether they've got better
and comfortable Wars I'm used to death
know when you've had someone breathing
next to you sort of a couple of hours
before and the next minute we're dead
[Music]
it is the loneliness of dying wood kovat
that is affected staff the most doctors
nurses and those tasked with the
responsibility of comforting the
bereaved at the peak of the pandemic the
hospital's mortuary was in danger of
being overwhelmed the hospital coped but
the heartbreak of forced isolation has
taken its toll
whilst you really I found every day I
was coming into work does not know what
to expect and we've sort of like
adrenaline from when you first come in
night you just don't know many days go
in and it's only when you you know
manage to go home you can sort of
reflect on your day I think during the
whole thing the hardest time or points
have been they limited viewings on other
wards or families so we had to do the
same down here so we did occasionally
get families calling and that wanted to
come and see in their their loved ones
and we weren't able to always to always
do that for though we said that was
quite hard
less stressed which is a good thing but
I think we're all still very anxious
just in case we do get a second peak
just to see what happens
[Music]
the threat of a second wave hangs over
the Hospital's emergency department it's
one of the busiest in the country the
fear of Kovac has kept patients away hey
now we'd lock down easing and the pubs
and bars reopening Edie is getting busy
gary is back in hospital he's been
struggling to walk because of breathing
problems for emergency consultant dr.
Ali has saying the uptick is welcomed
the missing patients were a worry and
it's challenging we are still in the
grip of a pandemic the problem is is
that nobody's going to stay around for a
long time
and it's now time to balance how we go
back to what we had before whilst
maintaining what we were we've tried to
sort an Institute for it so it's a bit
of a juggling act to be honest with you
before we were dealing with just any
patients and that was fine then we
changed the way when we worked how we
were dealing with desperate patients now
we're gonna have to try and marry the
two together Lester the size of a
localized outbreak is not far from here
staff have barely recovered from the
first outbreak and they know a second
wave is possible we as a hospital have
responded very well to the first wave
and I've been very happy with how we've
been able to cope so as bad as it will
be having gone through the first wave
almost like a trial run I think I'm kind
of confident that we'll be able to
handle it
the emergency department has undergone
significant change the waiting room is
gone
walk-in patients are triaged before they
get inside the hospital there are new
systems in place designed to keep the
hospital kovat free to protect patients
and staff wherever you look in this
hospital you will see transformation
forced change because of the corona
virus pandemic this hospital will never
be the same again and nor will the NHS
the real change is not so visible kovat
19 has demanded a flexibility rarely
seen in an organization this size red
tape was slashed allowing decisions to
be taken quickly for new technologies to
be adopted and implemented the scale and
pace of change unthinkable precoded I
think the role is to learn is less over
off this hospital there will be the
nation and I'd like us to learn them in
a non blame wipe the NHS for too long
has been apply so if it wasn't invented
here we don't do it none of that anymore
this is about who does things the best
who can we learn from how can we bring
into our hospitals
[Music]
tanya has been told she can go home it's
time for baby Sofia to be reunited with
dad James you could escape from your
first night as a family together that's
not so great
yep
[Music]
when she is old enough Sofia will learn
about a pandemic the dedication of
medical workers and a National Health
Service that was forced to change
[Music]